cindy se ingeniera en prevención de
riesgos fue la primera en su familia de
origen humilde en tener una carrera que
solo pudo financiar a través de uno de
los créditos con aval del estado el cahe
lleva tres años pagando y le quedan
pendientes 17 años más la noticia de que
gabriel boric condonará la deuda del cae
a partir de 2023 es una reivindicación
que no esperaba y me dio una esperanza
alegría
yo creo que boris también él sabe sabe
en la realidad de las personas que
estamos con el caer y es y yo espero de
verdad que espero que esto se pueda
concretar
es como mi anhelo en realidad en los 100
días del mandato del presidente también
hay elementos negativos que afectan la
vida de los chilenos como el incremento
de la delincuencia y el alza importante
en los precios conoce los datos de
inflación interanual 2021 2022
no se conocían en este país hace 30 años
niveles de inflación cercanos al 11 11 5
por ciento aumentó el ipc en el
interanual y estamos teniendo noticias
del banco central chileno de alza
sistemática de la tasa interés lo que va
a poner un alto nivel de complejidad y
presión sobre la gestión del presente
ahora siento albornoz es uno de los
afectados por la inflación hace nueve
meses abrió un restaurante las medidas
del gobierno de entregar subsidio a las
pequeñas y medianas industrias ayudará a
cumplir con el recién decretado aumento
del salario mínimo para sus trabajadores
pero bueno súper bueno porque cuando a
mí me tocó ser empleado en una empresa
el sueldo mínimo era muy bajo de
alcanzar realmente para
arrendar un departamento pueden arrendar
una pieza tal vez o vivir en conjunto
con algunos amigos aunque son muchos los
problemas por resolver algunos chilenos
ven positivamente las medidas anunciadas
por el gobierno de boris en la última
cuenta pública la duda razonable es si
los cambios profundos en helados durante
décadas para lograr un chile menos
desigual y una vida más digna para todos
podrán realmente concretarse